I think as somebody who sits here in
Silicon Valley the trends that I find
really interesting I think we're in the
very earliest stages of mobile computing
both for how the younger generation uses
devices to communicate with each other
how they'll build businesses that
communicate with their customers I also
think what we're learning about the
human body is nothing short of
spectacular how the brain works how our
body reacts to drugs how our body reacts
to chemicals in the environment and how
it's different on an individual by
individual basis some of the stuff that
the human species is coming up with
right now is truly spectacular and very
exciting what that will lead to in terms
of businesses the entrepreneurs will
show us I'm super excited about what I
think are gonna be a whole host of next
computing platforms you know it's the
smart house it's the smart building it's
the smart body so you know I think the
next big thing is really sort of these
new frontiers of computing technology
and seeing how they turn into
standardized platforms you know it's
it's hard to imagine how those are going
to turn out now but we can clearly see
that there are people going after
standardizing each of these categories
and you know we're going to turn around
in ten years and there will be very
clear you know operating systems for a
house and for a commercial building and
for a car that you know are hard to
imagine today
I believe one of the next big things
that we're gonna see is machine assisted
services or products there's been a lot
of talk about artificial intelligence
the benefits as well as potential
dangers of fully automated robots robots
that could make their own decisions
that's of lively and valid debate but I
believe that before we we reach this
point of highly intelligent robots or
fully autonomous robots be the cars or
whatever form they take we're gonna see
actually a much wider spread of machine
assistive services where the machine is
not in tight taking over a task entirely
but humans are being assisted by machine
by algorithms like data to make much
better decisions to perform at a much
higher level of productivity I'm a busy
mom and so for me I would say the next
big thing is anything that saves time so
whether that be
instacart for example or Google Shopping
Express so Google Shopping Express came
to my town and of course I tried it out
because it was free and I remember
thinking at some point this is not going
to be free and they're gonna charge me
two for this service and I thought I'm
not gonna fall for it and then six
months down the road they sent me an
email and said your free account is over
and you need to pay I don't know hundred
dollars for the year and I was so
addicted to Google Shopping Express that
I happily paint the hundred dollars
because now I need my toilet paper in
four hours
you know I perceive I do and then all of
a sudden it shows up in four hours and I
am so delighted by that so for me that's
what I would say everything that saves
me time I that you know I'm willing to
pay for and I think that as people see
the value that chances are they might be
willing to pay as well
what we're seeing now the automobile is
now being opened up it's like a
workplace so there's been a lot of very
large companies being built to go after
the home market to go after the
workplace market but think about how
many hours are spent in a car and the
opportunity to address consumer issues
or problems or opportunities in that car
and that's just a great area that we're
seeing a lot of activity because the
cars now opened up for a number of
companies to offer their product the
best ideas in terms of change in the
world are ones that people don't
actually know they want until after they
see them until they after they see the
idea a simple example is uber who would
decide to go build another taxi service
and it just doesn't sound like a smart
idea to do yet they came up with a
completely new model it's not a tech
companies technology enabled company but
they came of a completely new model and
a way to disrupt an industry that until
you saw you didn't really think about it
and that's like that's a great idea so
we don't know where the next credit I
will say this we live in a you know here
in Silicon Valley I think of it as the
Florence of the 21st century the font of
all innovation and change of the world
the underlying technology continues to
to to give to the community I see you
know 50 years behind us and I see at
least 50 years in front of us of
increasingly capable technology which
entrepreneurs are going to look at and
have a vision that no one else has and
be able to change the world in ways that
we don't even understand